tocantins mas muito obrigada pela
apresentação sinto muito lisonjeada é
votar todos acho que é possível votar
certo ainda que acham pessoas
tá bom dia voltar pra lá totti o nome
silva rosa tem 18 anos
a eu neste momento sou digital e não
consegue influenciar não gosto dessa
palavra eu gosto de ser normalmente sou
do edital contendo creator que não
querem cumprida mas hoje em dia tanto as
denominações por é o nosso trabalho que
ele fique no domingo que quer dizer
assim tenho 18 anos e conceito desta
minha aventura é com 12 anos há seis
anos atrás e eu brincar a brincar eu eu
tenho tido oportunidades incríveis com o
primeiro chaque hoje eu já queria ter
toda a gente tá aqui estarem presentes e
promove espero que gostem já vejo que os
meus cartões foi mais forte do que eu
não conseguiria importante mas sim
aconselhamento de toda a 600 jogos
ficarão que ele olhe como tudo isto
começou mas primeiro acho que tem ferir
aqui marcar porque nós somos uma
sociedade a mesma geração bastante
privilegiada por e temos acesso ao mundo
com apenas um clique a tecnologia tem
rendimentos ao longo dos anos e sem
dúvida que o fato nós mesmos criamos
oportunidades os nossos pontos de vista
e perspectivas e tão facilmente consegue
ter tanta gente a ver as nossas coisas e
ver os nossos filhos e ver as nossas
fotos
é incrível é uma coisa que há uns anos
atrás nós tentarmos conseguir fazer e
hoje em dia é é ótimo
é esse mais ou menos mas ela diz que o
faça o trabalho com toda forma digitais
ou seja tem um canal no youtube que
chama se virem
lá eu falo um pouquinho de moda inglesa
opiniões - basicamente eu gosto de falar
tudo aquilo que o paciente irmã ou seja
o meu cantinho e também trabalha com o
instagram
ao sair já com publicidade e assim e
pronto faz tu itz enquanto vou colocando
assim com um seguidores
é mas agora vamos à parte da como é que
tudo isso começou a eu gosto de chamar
isso é fase de webcam
por quê ou seja quando tinha 10 anos eu
era uma rapariga muito fina eu nunca
tive muitos amigos na escola sempre que
ela já poderia ficar vão cair no canto
porque não me identificava com muitas
pessoas nunca te acho que sempre tive um
carinho das áreas e então eu acho super
sic tem uma faceta na escola super
feminina terá fia o bicho do mato
ninguém falava se muito comigo e quando
chegava a casa e agrava tirar
fotografias em manhãs das polícias ea
fotografia seu popular e ficava toda
vaidosa
uma coisa que eu mandava fazer é ampliar
meu pai às vezes coitado estava lá eu
trabalhar a mandar emails cansado depois
de um dia de trabalho ele é sempre o pai
e gravação vídeo aqui enquanto é
bicampeão que quero gravar e surge ainda
dava tempo inteiro o computador com
vírus e coisas interessantes porque ele
é só isso que foi na altura
até que um dia eu depararem com o
youtube três anos atrás cá em portugal
que não tinha dimensão têm hoje
e lá fora já tem alguma eu acabei por
ver um vídeo do mito brasileira que
chama camila coelho que trará alguém que
conhece alguém conhece aquela coisa aqui
é é uma das maiores vencedoras
brasileiras neste momento também no
mundo e há seis anos atrás ela fazia
vídeos com um tijolo ou seja organizada
uma péssima qualidade e eu às vezes dava
por mim é ver 20 minutos dela falar só
maquiagem quando na altura nem sequer
uma criava
ou seja estava vendo que minuto pra mim
mas eu adorava ver aqui o agora vou e
vou ganhar um campo que nem vou passar
você que o primeiro videoclipe favor só
15 segundos no máximo
isto é muito mau duzentos que está hoje
a fazer um vídeo vai ser um evento na
carne
joão i copa de área vinha tentando há 14
anos
em nota à vontade
ouça a faixa com vocês podem ver
obrigada vocês podem ver nesta altura é
tudo menos difícil fazer vídeos mito
tanto é assim que o motivo isto com
segredo durante esse tempo em branco o
animal ainda consegue esconder isso meus
amigos é verdade é que hoje em dia está
com quase 200 mil visualizações e tá
parecendo um telex
eu acho que há seis anos atrás me
dissessem assim olha daqui a seis anos
ele vai aparecer na tv como a sala cheia
de pessoas
eu nunca queria voltar aqui o vídeo
nunca porque não cria as suas vizinhas e
getafe genético ninguém lhes faz muito
sentido
enfim eu fui crescendo 8 ou seja isto já
faz parte da vida bastante tempo
nesta altura uma briga bastante
ineficiente ou seja conservar as coisas
com muita naturalidade as duas foram
descobrindo o canal do youtube foram
vendo os meus vídeos e obviamente que eu
tive pessoas que achavam que nunca iria
desabar por incluir na escola mas não
sabem porquê nem como mas é que eu
passava muito lato droga agravado aqui o
escravo nem era porque não ligava muito
a opinião por que não eram bem meus
amigos então eu sempre joguei um tênis e
eu acho que isso tudo trouxe tantas
coisas boas e hoje em dia e sem que
nenhuma pessoa muito mais madura graças
a isso a china uma maneira bastante o
lado oculto acho que podia ter
acontecido por exemplo identificar uma
pessoa muito convencida ou uma pessoa
que começa a ligar muita fama porque
hoje em dia eu fui de mandar um carinho
às vezes as pessoas vêm a fama com uma
qualidade ao ganho já estava com uma
qualidade é uma coisa que acontece
eu acho que as coisas têm corrido muito
pior mas eu acho que também teve um
ótimo complemento da minha família e vem
com tudo bem
também aprendi a valorizar bastante a
minha privacidade eu acho que só dão
valor às coisas quando alexandra ter e
hoje em dia em mais por isso e também ao
empenho porque eu já trabalhei estou
seja ela trabalha na altura conceito com
óbvio ou seja eu acho que ela também foi
isso que ajudou a aquecer também com
isto porque na altura eu tenho exército
e até dia 16 com minha irmã nós
ajustamos gravaram vídeos e diz que o
computador
buscamos a publicar eu não sei como
consegui comecei meus pais e plantas
daninhas desta maneira e agora voltaram
que vinha atrás
a planta já falar só como foi no começo
acho que também não é interessante
quando perguntam qual é afinal aqui o
trabalho quantas vezes aqui pronto a
explodir às vezes quando vou no gol
assim eu vou fazer aquela conversinha
produto na viagem mais agradável
às vezes tocando no carro e fica lá ela
tem a certeza se ela tem como dizer
agora que temos uma empresa de
comunicação
minto e rindo à toa nas aulas que eu
faço hoje público porque às vezes
ficaram queridinhas do conceito do meu
trabalho que é difícil porque como é
tudo tão conscientes eu acho que esses
caras fazem não peço profissão
queridinho do lazio no sentido em que
para lá mas faz vídeos é esse tipo a que
só fazem isso não trabalhou com as
portagens programa também faço isso mas
é um ser que o tubo e trabalhar com
plataformas digitais é muito mais do que
isso envolve muito mais organização e
autodisciplina mexe eu acho que à
primeira vista este trabalho parece
perfeito porque não têm horários não tem
patrão o que é ótimo também trabalha em
casa se quiser trabalhar em casa de
pijama ou como meta nas pernas tão à
vontade porque ninguém está a ver se
estou no escritório é também seu
produtos piratas também é bom eu vou
enviados 500 pessoas mas a verdade é que
este trabalho também acaba por ser uma
opção constante porque eu nunca desligue
e muitas vezes sinto que não tem férias
porque as pessoas é eles gostam de ver
quantas vezes é que já fez férias de
verão e depois tudo por mim a gravar e
meus filhos lá ou seja este trabalhar o
que entendo muito de mim e da
criatividade às vezes forçar
criatividade é possível acho que é uma
das piores coisas que podem fazer porque
não posso negar que pra mim também é
verdade que marcou a sua vida qualquer
outra coisa que pode fazer uma coisa é
uma coisa complicada que foi uma coisa
que às vezes sai com o tempo e fez a
criatividade das quinas que as coisas e
aí ficou fácil então
pensar tanque nisto há outra coisa que
eu acho que também é das piores delito é
a mesma disposição porque essas coisas
acabam por ser uma bola de neve e já
teve fase em que gravava um vídeo todos
os dias que eram os vlogs diárias e dava
por mim a partilhar a minha casa a
partilhar os meus amigos muitas vezes a
minha escola e sei lá às vezes quando
ponho a minha volta em si para buscar
aquela pessoa já vi que minha casa mas
nunca como diria eu convidei aquela
pessoa pobre lá não tem confiança das
pessoas
agora ela já sabe como é que a cor da
minha cozinha
quais são os pontos que 8 que o uso quem
são os meus amigos eu já sei já sei os
comentários nem tu quer a cia não vamos
colocar o texto não viajar com ele
assim está com seu príncipe pode ver que
quanto mais as pessoas têm mais querem
mas mas querem ser da minha vida e
pronto eu acho que outra parte uma de
outubro também é bom ao mesmo tempo é
que qualquer pessoa pode fazer vídeos
qualquer pessoa está aqui nesta sala
pode criar uma conta no youtube e
começaram a publicar os vídeos que
quiser
obviamente que está acontecendo vai
fazer com que imaginem sem vídeos 90 vão
ser maus e 10 vão ser bons porque por
uma hesitante as pessoas a maioria do
conteúdo vai ser mau e é escrava por
isso sei eu sei se as crianças forem à
plataforma e dito e eu por nossas vidas
cuja presença de funcionários muito mal
e tudo muito grande me estranho eu sei
que isso é que acho que é dessa maneira
que as pessoas começamos a pôr tudo no
mesmo saco e aí começa a acontecer
ninguém teve a palavra tour até porque
vocês certeza que já viram notícias na
televisão na rádio quando temos muito
bem guardado não falou diretamente de um
mas também não falam bem é um grande
objetivo do gênero ou e dinheiro fácil
ou sei lá
dizem que somos uma má influência para
os jovens e
eu e 51 na opção nisso mas eu sei que
muitos nós conseguimos influenciar
bastante jovens com os nossos filhos e
acho que é preciso ter muito cuidado mas
acho que as pessoas generalizam bastante
e acho que é uma parte má do facto
estrito sertão é aberto por assim dizer
outra coisa é que o que eu quero dizer
pra quem não tiver muita partido não
está aqui muita gente com os homens mas
os números não são qualidade e claro que
às vezes é às vezes a vida são muito
bons e têm muitas visualizações
mas eu não quero que vocês vão ao
youtube e veja um vídeo com muitas
visualizações e pensa em ter mais filhos
deve ser o melhor ataque não há muito
mais por onde furar you e é só tirar
nenhum cliente tempo pra ir mais a fundo
porque há tanto conteúdo bom às vezes
tantas pessoas que não são conhecidas e
tem tanto pra eu dizer que tanto para
sustentar mas acabam por não ter visões
porque às vezes não é o conteúdo que o
fato que não é contínuo fácil quando ele
que foi o tubo nas pessoas é vamos ver
duas reações ou continência obesidade
cumpre-se pra mim é um cara engraçado o
efeito fica às vezes eu usei a palavra
um carinha do gênero foi lá e não sou só
eu to work faz mais coisas que eu faço a
gente não queria um limitador venceram
que ninguém grátis mas o próprio sangue
escalar conseguir ter mais vezes no
canal é o seu talvez fizesse vídeos que
com títulos mais bebe abrasileirado
estão a ver coisas mais básicas e se
calhar eu sei que conseguia ter mais
dias a questão é que eu acho que é muito
importante que nós temos princípios e
acima de tudo estamos aqui o que nós
fazemos porque nós nem nós que estamos
chegando a identificar com linhas que eu
faço não está com os títulos que eu faço
as pessoas também não vão gostar ou até
podem estar mas qual é qual é
eu sei que vou ganhar com isso
visualizações eu acho que há muito mais
profunda e estrutural em itu
e para concluir eu quero dizer estou
muito feliz porque eu sei agora da
escola assim 12º ano não fui para a
faculdade não é algo que eu queria te
catar de todos porque eu acho que é
muito importante aprender mais e acho
mas nunca é mais fácil de ser linda é
verdade e é uma coisa que eu quero fazer
no futuro mas eu estou agora a trabalhar
com minha irmã 100% problemas as duas
juntas e plantas que é ideal porque a
época em que eu mais confio é que eu
mais gosto também é e as minhas irmãs e
seus colegas em um e pronto e confirme
esteve o facto mais ficar com ela
simplesmente estamos agora a viver as
duas sozinhas está a ser uma uma
expressão que estranharam a vitória o
querem mas me sinto muito feliz e acho
que são mais importantes e e e poder
também não fiz isso com vossa profissão
e é isso obrigada por virem obrigado
pelo convite e fazer o gol
[Aplausos]